jess is with us in Springfield
Massachusetts hi Jess how are you I'm
good how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up I'm trying to I'm
thinking about consolidating my student
loans
I paid off like fifteen thousand last
year on them and I still have about 22
thousand last 22 three left and I have
four federal little one or not little
they are twelve thousand and then I have
two privates which are ninety five
hundred and I didn't know if I should
consolidate them and do like a variable
or a fixed rate and I still have about
five thousand on a car left
you cannot consolidate government and
private they won't go together but you
can do two to the two government ones
and the only reason to do that would be
if you got a lower rate have you gotten
a quote yeah I can get a variable at
four or a fixed at five to seven and
right now my two private student loans
is four thousand at five percent and
then five thousand that nine percent
that the four percent variable wasn't
for private was it yeah it was
what's the fix on the private uh the
fixed would be around five or seven
percent five to seven percent okay well
you've already got five fixed right yeah
okay well we wouldn't go up yeah the
only reason the consolidate is to save
on interest it would never be you never
go up in interest because if you take
two individual loans the total ninety
five hundred and you pay a thousand
dollars a month on that or you take one
loan that's ninety five hundred you pay
a thousand dollars a month on that it
pays off in exactly the same period of
time if it's exactly the same interest
rate so two loans into one is never a
reason to consolidate any time but you
might do it if it saves you interest now
here's the thing you're not gonna save
on this to buy a cup of coffee
let's say you saved one percent on 9,500
how fast you're gonna have this 22,000
paid off one year probably 14 months yep
yep okay so half of the year the 9500 is
gone right and so you yeah I was
probably gonna pay the federal but
either way you're saving you're saving
six months of interest and at one
percent and so we're talking about 40
bucks
it just doesn't make any one percent of
nine hundred ninety five hundred is
ninety five dollars for the whole year
okay mm-hmm that's all you're saving and
you're not gonna save me more than that
because I would never go to variable I
would only do fixed and in that case
you're not gonna save enough money to
mess with this so I think you're the
secret sauce interest rates not your
problem the fact that you're pissed off
at debt and beaten in the face and
hitting it with a bat and cut in there
with a knife that's why you're going to
win get violent it's not yeah it's just
it's just not interest rate
mathematically it's 40 bucks so we're
talking about it just it's not it's not
worth the trouble I wouldn't screw with
it if I were you I would just just get
mad turn it up cut cut back on something
around the house and listen knock it out
as fast as we can I think you're 14
months sounds about right let's get her
done
it's that simple it's that hard it's
that easy it's that difficult that's
what it comes down to